what is up everybody at Santa Mac and
welcome to another installment of our
week's best anime videos where you guys
can come to catch up and all the fun
stuff that you missed in the past week
the links told the videos that we
mentioned are right there in the
description and if you want to recommend
a video for next week leave it in the
comments this past Tuesday on the day of
the American presidential election we
organized our very first live stream
here at Anime uproar the live stream was
called election 2016 anime edition and
we discussed which anime characters we
thought would make a good president a
huge thank you to everyone was able to
join us for the live stream we really
appreciate it guys and if you weren't
able to join us you can still watch the
video the link is right there in the
description another huge thank you to
our special guests who joined us for the
livestream Macklin lot and simply rose
those guys are awesome anime youtubers
and they really walked us through the
whole ice cream process because it was
our first time and those guys are more
experienced than we are the links to
their channels are in the description so
be sure to check them out and yeah
thanks again everybody we had a great
time we had a blast and we will
definitely be doing more live streams in
the future so stay tuned now if you just
can't get enough of the endless fun that
is the u.s. presidential election on the
day after the election you cook uploaded
a hilarious parody video about the
election results this video has
everything out of touch Hillary epic
dragon ball z style battles and spoiler
alert Trump as the Emperor of Britannia
glass reflection uploaded a video this
week called his Drifters worth watching
where he gives us the reaction to the
first five episodes of this anime
drifters pits famous historical figures
against each other this enemy actually
comes from the creator of Helsing and it
features a lot of crazy action sequences
and badass characters are cut off from
glass reflection definitely things that
drifters is worth watching if you're
into action and cool badass characters
so I will be checking it out for sure
and if you're wondering if you should
watch drifters this is a great video to
watch mystique ranexa created another
top 10 list this week shocking and this
is an interesting one top 10 shows to
get your girlfriend or boyfriend into
anime if you are looking to induct your
significant other into the sacred
Brotherhood of anime fans definitely
check this out I'm
you owe it to yourself and your loved
ones to force them all to watch anime
don't you watchmojo uploaded an
interesting list this week top 10
coolest travel destinations for anime
fans I thought that this was a really
useful and interesting list for all
hardcore anime fans and if you're
planning a trip to Japan sometime soon
and you want to do some serious anime
related tourism be sure to check it out
and there was another list that I really
like this week but don't worry this is
the last one I promise a massive youtube
channel called dorkly huge youtuber
right scares huge youtuber uploaded a
list of nine anime cliches that are
secretly awesome now I never heard about
this channel before and it features like
a muppet type of thing talking about
anime but I thought it was really funny
and interesting so definitely check it
out finally my favorite AMV this week
was also for the anime drifters and it
was made by youtuber called honest man
AMV this sam v features a badass rock
cover of the song rise by katy perry and
it's definitely great to pump yourself
up before a great battle or a big exam
or whatever you're into definitely give
it a watch and a listen and that's it
for this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space cowboys
walked off command I'm recording